there's fury at the police amid repeated
claims which refused to go away about
police brutality when dealing with these
pro-democracy demonstrators it is
chaotic on Hong Kong streets and this is
now turning into a nightly ritual
outside one police station a floral
Mountain is building a tribute to
protesters they believe have died after
being arrested claims the police have
categorically denied but trust in the
police is at an all-time low now earlier
the police had moved on mass to the
international airport setting up
roadblocks several kilometers away from
the terminals checking everyone entering
had valid boarding passes we saw a huge
line of buses stopped by the police so
they could search and check passengers
details at the airport itself police
closed most entrances to try to thwart
protesters who'd threatened to disrupt
operations here again they've been
determined to keep the international
airport open every time there's been a
disruption it's cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars never mind the
untold damage to Hong Kong's reputation
there were repeated announcements
warning that the airport had a court
injunction preventing any individual or
group gathering to protest
in the absence of any group the police
moved in on individuals one older woman
on her own who'd been calling for more
democratic freedom was identified by the
dozens of police as a risk to the
airport business and asked to leave
she was relocated to the bus terminal
but even while playing video games was
deemed too danger and told she was being
arrested
so to the astonishment of passers-by and
the assembled media she was marched into
a police van and taken away for
questioning it is very much a police
state right now the government is not
really engaged in any dialogue with the
protesters it's not looking for any
constructive solution they're just using
the police as a wall to quell the
protests but it's not going to solve
anything and it is not going to make the
lives of people who live here of any
better trust in the authorities has been
the biggest casualty in Hong Kong's
democracy demonstrations Alex Crawford
Sky News Hong Kong